company has come out with an app yeah an
iphone app that can actually detect
cancer and other diseases we've got some
more info for you it is called the sniff
phone it's the nanos breathalyzer and by
identifying the special odor emitted by
cancer cells the nanos system can detect
the presence of tumors both benign and
malignant more quickly efficiently and
cheaply than previously possible we've
got a little more information the plan
calls for a chip with nanotechnology to
be installed in a device that is
attached to a smartphone and for an apt
to read the sensor data analyzing it on
the device nano system has a ninety
percent accuracy rate so basically
you're just connecting sign to your
phone you blow in it and then ninety
percent I mean this is this is really
incredible like we think I think about
apps that we all love an Instagram and
Twitter and blah blah blah but like this
is kinda interactive right next year
breathalyzer I have yeah right so first
you make sure you're not drunk that's
good you blow into that and they tell
you if you have halitosis I would
imagine that it probably good because it
does other other condition is a question
I mean we I know you brought up as you
know iphone app yeah I mean other
Android users screwed on this do we not
well they got the leasing right you get
a tumor no hair yeah yeah generally they
release these things to the iphone first
and then your people you know it comes
around I mean this is just great right
like this is just this is just such a
beautiful use of technology well I
wasn't it can they put that into the
robot dog and it can be like sniff out
bombs or something robot dog what you
talking about there's an annotation
right here from earlier right well but
these are all the things that they'll be
able to do right so they'll be able to
attach this technology probably to sniff
out by mean all this stuff although
again here's this is we get this is
everything's tying together this week uh
who gets access to that information once
your phone knows that you have cancer ah
so these are saying it's not just
between you and your doctor suddenly
it's out there for whoever is looking at
what's going on you know amazingly i
love to go in that direction with all
these stories I wasn't just gonna focus
on the good
uh the good parts of this is there some
risk in here maybe that when we are able
to detect all the stuff on our own that
maybe we wouldn't go to proper doctors
actually because even with a ninety
percent success rate i'm gonna guess
that there's a disclaimer when they
start selling this thing that's saying
you know you still should go to your
doctor and get a checkup and all I mean
you can have a false you know false
positive yeah I'm sure you know and so
in that aspect then you do wonder people
then go oh I'd not in this people who
like to take their you know their own
remedies yeah uh they're like you know
what the doctors pumping into them all
that stuff so that may rise but the
first thought is that overall cases of
least late notifications will lower
which i think is great yeah of course I
mean everyone i think has been affected
in some way uh from someone there was
they had cancer sir i think everyone can
is not too bad things you can find out
there there's definitely it's mostly
upside i'm just being alarmist because
i'm paying you today but now that you
know that out of the thing also is i
mean are people going to their doctors
offices and taking the cancer
breathalyzer like i've never heard about
like you people having tumor breath
before but that's that that's the genius
of this thing like they figured out i
was a blood test or you know cat scans
and things right well that's what i'm
saying that i guess there would be some
risk in that this thing you know it's
not a hundred percent but i would
imagine that most of those tests i I
guess what I'm saying is that there's
sort of two levels going on here whether
there's an app that they'll do all this
but secondly there's a breathing test
that tells you the you have cancer like
that's maybe I'm just not hard to
believe following the news but I've
never heard of this well because these
freakin scientists they're hanging out
in science places all the time work on
science when we're up here yes i knows
what anyway this is pretty cool i don't
see any way around it what do you think
let us know in the comments right down
below